si el ataque se ha producido muy
temprano esta mañana cuando varios
misiles impactaron contra una planta de
reparación de aviones una planta ubicada
cerca de un barrio residencial de esta
ciudad que además está cogiendo una
enorme cantidad de desplazados pero
también una planta ubicada cerca del
aeropuerto de libia y recordemos que
este aeropuerto es uno de los pocos de
ucrania que siguen activos y que siguen
recibiendo suministro hemos hablado con
algunos de los testigos que se
encontraban en el lugar en el momento
del ataque y nos han relatado que las
sirenas antiaéreas se dispararon poco
después de las seis de la mañana y que
después de esa o menos de ese momento
pocos minutos después oyeron la primera
explosión mientras también siguen
llegando informaciones de nuevos ataques
en particular en el este del país en la
región del donbass donde las autoridades
ucranianas han denunciado una bombardeo
en la ciudad de ramat 8 y también en
quiebre en la capital de ucrania se
siguen oyendo explosiones en particular
procedentes de la zona de los seguros de
esta ciudad